after more than 30 years of restrictions
farmers in the EU will now be able to
produce as much milk as they want the
dairy sector will no longer be regulated
by the quota scheme which imposed limits
on milk production on the 31st of March
2015 the quota regime comes to an end so
there will be no meal quotas anymore and
though we see the product of this
happening today the decision the
political decision was made in 2003 when
the council decided to bring this regime
to a conclusion in order to allow the
sector to start its path toward a
greater market orientation the shift
towards the markets will allow European
producers to export more and to compete
better with producers from the United
States and Australia they will also
benefit from the growing demand for
dairy produce in the world the quotas
put limits on the amounts of liquid milk
as well as milk powder yogurts and
cheese but why were the restrictions
imposed in the first place milk quotas
were introduced in 1984 and at the
beginning they were meant to last only
five years and to address the problem of
surpluses so to control the milk
production and guarantee stability for
both milk prices and the income of the
farmers but then they were extended and
extended until it was decided that they
should come to an end the milk quotas
were a way of cutting over supply and
putting an end to the so-called butter
mountains and milk lakes the national
quota of every member state was
distributed among individual producers
producers exceeding their individual
quota had to pay fines or surplus levies
farmers have a lot to gain from the
abolition of the scheme but at the same
time there are concerns so what is the
post quota future for the dairy sector
the market outlook for
the dairy sector is positive the world
demand is expected to grow especially in
emerging countries therefore the
European farmers have good possibilities
in the medium-term however in the short
term we have seen a decrease significant
decrease in prices and the introduction
of the Russian ban on EU food products
and this has impacted farmers very hard
and especially in some Member States
therefore the end of quotas is both a
big opportunity but also a challenge as
its last meeting in March the
Agriculture Council called for close
monitoring of the milk sector as
producers adapt to the new situation